right yeah so um so so my next question
was that we know that you know God
taught that that incest is bad that hat
incest you mean yeah yeah it's it's an
Abomination he hates it but my my
question was you know when so when Adam
and Eve had had children you know they
were the only people on Earth so
wouldn't those children have had
to do that for to populate Earth you're
killing me brother I want to hang myself
okay now because I love you sorry when
you say incest is bad we know it's bad
yes why is it
bad why is it
bad
um well I would say
because I would say because if there if
there were children from it they they
would be sick they wouldn't be
healthy that's why it's bad so what if
you don't get sick that means you can go
sleep with your sister now no but it's
also just because it's not the I don't
know I guess just because it's not the
purpose that that that God gave us our
sexuality okay so it's because God said
it's bad
right yes and when did he say it's bad
and for what reason he said it was bad
when when he when he said when he told
how the how he was going to punish the
Nations for their that comes later time
of Moses right yeah okay meaning why do
you
assume that because something is now
prohibited and forbidden in light of the
current situation that people find
themselves in that automatically that
prohibition applies to an earlier period
when you don't have enough human beings
to procreate and preserve the human
race okay yeah that that makes
sense so if we do not follow how the
Bible
progressively unfolds God's purpose and
will for
mankind you're going to create
contradiction problems that do not exist
because you're going to be reading
something that comes later and think
that this has always been the norm even
for an earlier generation because if we
follow that logic when our lord Jesus
comes in the New Testament during the
New Covenant period And he says one man
one woman woman and there is no
dissolution of the marriage except for
marital
unfaithfulness which various Traditions
interpret variously if I now take that
and I look to the Old Testament that
means
Abraham
Jacob
David well we can put Solomon aside
because he had foreign wives all of
these men of God prophets of God even
those who are
righteous they all committed
adultery and Moses sanctioned adultery
by allowing them to have multiple wives
and by allowing them to divorce without
saying that the only valid reason you
can divorce is for sexual
immorality right yeah yeah I didn't yeah
now that I think of it it's a bit of a
silly question I didn't think of it
though it's not a silly question I just
want you know what she
saying let me just call it real quick
it's not a silly question it's just read
the Bible linear linearly and see how it
progresses because I'm going to show you
an example one second hold on my
daughter needs about to sleep it's okay
one second might show you an example you
can't marry your father's daughter right
according to Leviticus 18 and Leviticus
20 right right all right now watch here
I G to show you I'm just waiting see if
she picks up okay watch here now we got
a problem Houston Houston we got a
problem
Houston we got a problem okay watch here
Genesis 2012 but I'm GNA read 11- 13 let
me just tell her all right okay okay
Mommy I was trying to call you to say
good night because I'm on a live stream
but I love you all right anyway Genesis
20 11-13 Houston we got a problem now
who is Sarah Sarai let me just tell you
her importance you
ready you ready show you how important
she is all right let me show you
something you ready I'm want show you
something I'm like is this guy an answer
yeah no I I guess I know you think I can
read Hearts Dam bro
shoot you ready yep I'm
ready I don't think I'm ready now all
right you ready now bro
shoot so let me show you who Sarah is
how great she is
okay all right Genesis 17 I'm gonna
bring it up right here okay Genesis 17
15 to 21 okay let's read now Genesis 17
15 to 20 21 God also said to Abraham as
for Sarai your wife you are no longer to
call her Sarai her name will be Sarah
okay her name will be
Sarah I will bless her and will surely
give you a son by her I will bless her
so that she will be the mother of
Nations Kings of peoples will come from
her Abraham fell face down he laughed
and said to himself will a son be born
to a man 100 years old will Sarah bear a
child at the age of 90 and Abraham said
to God if only ishmail might live under
your blessing I already have ishmail
from Hagar her maid servant just bless
him now watch here look what God says
about
Sarah then God said yes I'll bless
Ismail but your wife Sarah will bear you
a son and you will call him Isaac I will
establish my Covenant with with him as
an Everlasting Covenant for his
descendants after him and as for Ishmael
I have heard you I will surely bless him
I'll make him fruitful and will greatly
increase his numbers he'll be the father
of 12 rulers and I'll make him into a
great nation who the son of
Sarah but my Covenant I'll establish
with Isaac whom Sarah will bear to you
by this time next year now now when I
ask you a question you can un mute you
see how God loves Sarah and exalt Sarah
and ures her son from Abraham will be
the heir the
Covenant yes so you got it now
right but guess who Sarah was you know
who Sarah was besides being Abraham's
wife do you know who she was besides
being Abraham's wife she was Abraham's
sister from the same father different
mother Genesis 2012 we're going to read
11-
13 watch here Genesis 12 but we're going
to read 11- 13 what that God had to
always protect Sarah from
being because Abraham told her don't
tell people you're my wife tell them
you're my sister which was partially
true that means Abraham didn't care
enough for
Sarah's safety he cared more about his
life and he was willing to have Sarah
ravage to spare his life and God at to
saor now watch
here Abraham told abik because he had
told AB oh she's my sister you can have
her and God appeared to said you're as
good as a dead man let her
go Abraham replied I said to myself
there is surely no fear of God in this
place and they will kill me because of
my wife besides she really is my sister
the daughter of my father though not of
my mother and she became my wife so
she's the daughter of my father from a
different mother but I married her
meaning God allowed it and God blessed
Sarah and made Sarah the mother of the
Covenant so if you read the later
command of Leviticus 18 and 20 and back
into this time period you're just said
that God blessed
incest all right and then let's finish
it and when God had me Wander from my
father's household I said to her this is
how you can show your love to me
everywhere we go say of me he is my
brother which is true she was his sister
he was her brother but she was also his
wife so if you read later prohibitions
back into an earlier time period you're
going to have God committing or
permitting immoral acts such as incest
and that God is simply
capricious but anyway now you can
respond and ask or go ahead you can ask
or respond whatever
yeah yeah that that that makes sense um
thank you for that uh I just have one
more one more quick question and then
I'll shut up um if you can ask me as
many as you want